hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live nach den heftigen Zusammenstößen
auf dem Tempelberg und in der al-axam
Moschee letzte Nacht heute nun das
Raketen auf Israel aus mehreren
Richtungen auch im Norden im aus dem
Libanon das wurde berichtet wurden 34
Raketen das sind die letzten Berichte
auf Israel abgefeuert mindestens zwei
Menschen sollen dabei verletzt worden
sein und nach israelischen
Medienberichten handelt es sich dabei um
den stärksten Beschuss aus dem Libanon
seit 2006 laut libanesischen Angaben
soll Israel Israel mit einem
Gegenangriff reagiert haben und dazu
wollen wir heute live sprechen zu diesen
aktuellen Entwicklungen ihr könnt Fragen
stellen wie immer direkt im Stream oder
per Mail und zuerst können wir fragen
stellen an unseren Korrespondenten live
in Tel Aviv an Michael Beverungen der
jetzt bei uns ist hallo schön dass du da
bist
hallo Michael klär uns doch mal kurz auf
zu der Lage ganz aktuell ich habe es
eben kurz geschildert also es gab einen
Angriff aus dem Libanon auf Israel den
heftigsten seit 2006 und ein
Gegenangriff soll es auch gegeben haben
wie ist die Lage jetzt in dem Moment bei
dir
also dieser Gegenangriff der Israelis
der ist nicht bestätigt was es gibt ist
eine offizielle Verlautbarung die
israelischen Armee dass die Hamas hinter
diesem massiven Raketenbeschuss steckt
das bedeutet erstmal dass die Hamas
offenbar einen neuen Organisationsgrad
im südlichen Libanon besitzt das
bedeutet dass sie sich eng mit der Iran
treuen Hess Boller vernetzt hat denn
ohne deren Zustimmung geht gar nichts im
südlichen Libanon und es bedeutet dass
die Hamas eben ganz bewusst als
Terrororganisation die sie ist eine
Strategie der Eskalation fährt sie will
sich hier in diesem Konflikt als
Retterin der Alexa Moschee des
Tempelbergs darstellen und im Prinzip
kann sie nur stark erscheinen wenn
Israel schwach da steht und wenn dieser
Konflikt auf einen höheren Gewalt Level
gehoben ist also das ist klar der
versuchte dahinter steckt die Frage ist
wird das funktionieren im Moment Tat
gerade das israelische
Sicherheitskabinett und Israel wird im
Moment von den Nachbarn von den
Palästinensern als schwach angesehen es
wird durch einen verfassungsstreit um
die Justizreform geschwächt der
Verteidigungsminister ist quasi nur
kommissarisch im Amt und gerade in
dieser Situation könnte das
Sicherheitskabinett Premiere Tanja auf
verleitet sein besonders heftig zu
reagieren um eben in diesem Moment
Stärke zu demonstrieren was das für die
Zukunft bedeutet zum Beispiel morgen für
den Karfreitag wo 10000 Pilger Christen
Muslime nach Jerusalem strömen das ist
noch offen aber dieser Entscheidung
steht noch aus sie ist noch nicht
getroffen das ist gerade angesprochen es
stehen also religiöse Feiertage an oder
werden auch schon gefeiert die Muslime
haben derzeit Ramadan das jüdische
Pessachfest wird gefeiert und die
Osterfeiertage stehen vor der Tür wie
groß ist die Sorge auch gerade in
Jerusalem wo eben diese tausenden
Menschen zusammenkommen von noch mehr
Eskalation jetzt
naja das alles findet halt nur wenige
hundert Meter voneinander entfernt die
Via Dolorosa ist vielleicht 100 Meter
Luftlinie vom Tempelberg darunter die
klageauer also das ist alles dicht
beieinander und wenn es ein Eskalation
des Konflikts gibt dann lässt er sich
nicht für die Umgebung einfach so
vermeiden es ist auf jeden Fall die
Frage ob es morgen tatsächlich zu
Eskalationen kommt es ist durchaus
wahrscheinlich jedenfalls lege das im
Kalkül der Herr Maas es gab ja auch eben
diese ganzen Auseinandersetzungen um den
Tempelberg das ist ja ein langes
fehlender Streit es gibt radikale Kräfte
in der israelischen Regierung die im
versuchen die Hoheit auf dem Tempelberg
die jüdische Hoheit auszuweiten die
Palästina sehen sich bedroht es gibt wie
jedes Jahr die Ankündigung und die
Auslobung von jüdischen Extremisten
jemand möge bitte eine Ziege auf dem
Tempelberg Schlachten damit er reagiert
dann die Hamas und sagt
das müssen wir verhindern dann kommen
die Jugendlichen verbarrikadieren sich
dann kommt die Polizei und sagt das
können wir nicht zulassen weil der sind
andere Pilger bedroht und so eskaliert
das immer weiter nach dem immer selben
Muster eigentlich aktuelle
Einschätzungen aus Tel Aviv live von
unserem Korrespondenten von Michael
Beverungen vielen Dank
und wir können jetzt noch mehr von euren
Fragen stellen an eine Expertin die wir
uns eingeladen haben eine Israel und
nahostexpertin es ist Professor Dr
Gisela DAX die jetzt bei uns ist sie
lehrt an der Hebräischen Universität in
Jerusalem wer erreichen Sie jetzt gerade
in Tel Aviv schön dass Sie da sind hallo
guten Abend wir haben gerade eben die
kurze aktuelle Einschätzung unseres
Korrespondenten gehört und haben auch
schon die ersten Fragen bei uns im
Stream und zwar von Monika schwarz die
bei Facebook wissen möchte woher weiß
man denn dass die Angriffe von der Hamas
kommen und nicht direkt von den anderen
Regierungen weil es sind ja viele
Akteure dort in der Region tätig
vielleicht können Sie uns mit Ruhe noch
mal dadurch führen und die Frage von
Frau Schwarz beantworten ja also
normalerweise sind tatsächlich ihm die
aus dem Libanon Raketen wenn sie
abgefeuert werden von der Hammer
was jetzt eigentlich ein neuer eine neue
Entwicklung ist das heißt also die hat
dafür keine Verantwortung übernommen und
alles weiß darauf hin dass es da eine
Gruppe der Hamas gibt die sich ebenfalls
da installiert hat in dieser Region und
die jetzt Raketen geschickt hat was die
was es erlaubt im Grunde zu sagen naja
also wir tun das von einer anderen Front
aus
so dass eigentlich ja Israel sich dann
überlegt in der Gegenreaktion ja jetzt
bestraft man jetzt den Libanon im
Gegenzug die Hamas ist nicht wirklich
Teil davon und das ist eigentlich ja so
Teil eines von vielen Fronten wo man im
Grunde Israel gerne angreifen möchte
aber zugleich sicherstellen möchte dass
dann die Gegenangriffe nicht im eigenen
Vorgarten stattfinden denn die Hamas
sitzt ja eigentlich im Gazastreifen im
Libanon und ist von dort aus dominant
und hat schickt normalerweise von dort
aus Raketen und solange die hitzboller
jetzt sich nicht zu diesen Angriffen
bekennt ist eben auch dieser verdeckte
kriegt zwischen Israel und dem Iran
nicht in erster erster Linie denn die
hitzboller wiederum kann nicht agieren
ohne dass der Iran das grüne Licht dafür
gibt also das ist jetzt Teil einer ja
ein von vielen Fronten die da
gleichzeitig aufgemacht sind und deshalb
ist diese Frage so relevant wer hat da
eigentlich jetzt geschossen denn alle
würden gerne diese Fronten miteinander
verbinden ohne eben es dann selber
auszutragen vielleicht sprechen wir noch
mal genau um diese ja seit Jahren
Jahrzehnten schon wir haben
entspannungsgeladene Region also weil
man muss ja wissen Israel Libanon
befinden sich offiziell im Kriegszustand
und es kommt also immer wieder an der
Grenze der beiden Staaten zu Spannung
aber das jetzt gerade also wir sehen
auch gerade die Region hier in in einer
Karte aber das was jetzt da gerade
passiert ist das wird ja schon als
schärfer eingestuft als sonst vielleicht
können Sie uns das noch mal genauer
erklären auch noch mal die Rolle der die
also mit dem Iran verbindet ist warum
ist das jetzt gerade vielleicht eine
neue Qualität
also zum einen muss man sagen die gute
Nachricht im Augenblick ist noch das ist
keine Getöteten und keine entführten
gibt das würde die Lage noch einmal
akuter machen seit 2006 das wurde auch
schon erwähnt ist es tatsächlich die
größte die größte Attacke aus dem aus
dem Libanon damals kam es zum ja mehr
wichtigen Krieg das war ziemlich heftig
und damit wurde auch die israelische
Abschreckung hergestellt also im Grunde
das Gleichgewicht der Abschreckung bitte
gut darauf dass Israel also sagt wenn
die hitzboller die sich im Süden des
Libanons Hunderttausende von Raketen die
immer stärker werden auch immer eine
größere Reichweite haben wenn sie sich
dieser Raketen bedient dann wird Israel
nicht nur gegen die hitzboller
zurückschlagen sondern dann wird auch
der Liebermann dafür bezahlen müssen und
das hat bisher als Abschreckung ganz gut
funktioniert die jetzt voller wiederum
ich habe es gesagt befindet sich im
Süden im Süden des Liebermanns ist aber
unter iranischer
einem Kommando sozusagen und der Libanon
an sich hat eigentlich keinen
Grenzkonflikt mit Israel mehr seitdem
sich Israel früher aus dieser
sogenannten Sicherheitszone aus dem
sieben Libanon 2000 zurückgezogen hat
könnte eigentlich zwischen den beiden
Staaten es in eigentlich keinerlei
Konflikte auszutragen zu geben und jetzt
die Spoiler die da nach wie vor sich
festgesetzt hat Iran nutzt eigentlich
die hitzboller um von dort aus Israel
anzugreifen oder zumindest zu bedrohen
und deshalb ist die Lage auch sehr sehr
brenzlig weil eigentlich ist diese
Auseinandersetzung eine zwischen Israel
und dem Iran
das passt die Frage von unserem User der
uns zusieht Ismael 04 dazu er sagt dass
es unter Lapid ja eine vorsichtige
Annäherung mit dem Libanon gegeben hätte
und fragt nun eskaliert unter Netanjahu
und dieser Regierung nun erneut die Lage
ob das der Grund sein möchte er gerne
wissen
das ist eine eine gute Frage ich denke
was sicherlich passiert ist dass die
israelische Abschreckung Schaden
genommen hat in den letzten drei Monaten
auch das wurde schon erwähnt also die
Proteste innerhalb Israels die also auf
eine Spaltung der Gesellschaft hinweisen
die aber auch auf eine eine neue
Situation hinweisen was die israelische
Armee angeht nämlich Reservisten die
gesagt haben also wenn diese Regierung
hier so weitermacht mit der Justiz
Reform werden keine zu keinen Übungen
mehr gehen als Piloten oder andere
Reserve Tätigkeiten innerhalb der Armee
das macht mich möglicherweise auch zu
falschen Schlussfolgerungen geführt
haben auf Seiten der oder der Hamas die
sagen das ist jetzt die Möglichkeit
anzugreifen Israel ist schwach so
schwach wie lange nicht was aber nicht
heißen würde dass nicht dem Ernstfall
natürlich die israelische Armee also
wenn es um einen wirklichen Krieg geht
natürlich werden da die Soldaten
mitmachen wie früher auch aber die
Situation ist tatsächlich eine
angespanntere kompliziertere denn die
israelische Regierung hat nicht kein
großes Vertrauen im Augenblick von sehr
vielen Israelis lassen sie uns da genau
noch mal mehr drauf eingehen sie haben
es gerade schon angesprochen also die
geplante Justizreform und auf die
Massenproteste auf die sie gestoßen ist
da gibt es ja auch noch eine
interessante Nebengeschichte oder eine
sehr spannende Geschichte dazu was die
in politische Lage aktuell so schwierig
macht denn der Verteidigungsminister
wurde eigentlich von Yahoo entlassen er
ist aber noch im Amt der
Verteidigungsminister galant der hatte
nämlich zum Stopp von netany ausgesetzt
ist Änderung für eben das jetzt dies
Justizwesen aufgerufen und es kam wie
wir alle ja auch beobachtet hatten in
den letzten Wochen zu den
Massenprotesten und müssten in so einer
Situation wie jetzt nicht eigentlich ein
der der Verteidigungsminister so
Entschuldigung der Verteidigungsminister
und eben der Ministerpräsident Hand in
Handarbeiten um die Situation zu
beruhigen wie schwierig macht das das
gerade dass man sich da so Spinne Feind
ist also der Verteidigungsminister ist
tatsächlich entlassen worden hat aber
nie einen offiziellen Entlassungsbrief
bekommen den es braucht um offizielles
Amt und toben zu werden weil die Lage
dann so angespannt war und die Proteste
erst richtig normal ausgebrochen sind
auf dieses auf diese Kündigung hat im
Grunde Ministerpräsidenten ja auch da
gesagt okay eigentlich einen Rückzieher
gemacht und in dem Amt gelassen quasi ja
ohne das groß zu erwähnen die beiden
sind auch zusammen mittlerweile
aufgetreten allerdings ohne miteinander
zwei Worte zu wechseln jetzt müssten sie
eigentlich zusammen sitzen in dem
Sicherheit Kabinett das im übrigen zwei
ganze Monate lang überhaupt nicht
zusammengetreten war und müssen darüber
beraten wie man jetzt weitermacht also
die entscheidenden Stimmen werden jetzt
seine Verteidigungsminister der
Ministerpräsident und der
Generalstabschef der Armee die
eigentlich jetzt entscheiden müssen wie
es weitergeht wie die nächsten Schritte
sind das ist die kleine Gruppe und ich
denke schon dass man davon ausgehen kann
dass die in der jetzigen Lage das machen
und ihre anderen Konflikte einfach
beiseiteschieben
Ernst ja und sie haben angesprochen dass
das natürlich auch Auswirkungen auf
außen hatte die Massenproteste im Land
die schwierige innenpolitische Lage ist
das ihrer Meinung nach auch der Grund
warum das jetzt eben zu den Raketen
Angriffen aus dem Libanon kam oder
gibt's da noch mehr Gründen dafür weil
der der Zeitpunkt jetzt auch gerade mit
diesen religiösen Feiertagen da stellt
sich ja schon die Frage warum jetzt es
ist sie haben natürlich von das schon
angesprochen die Ereignisse auf dem
Tempelberg und man hatte eine sehr
ähnliche Situation Situation vor zwei
Jahren
da war auch
Pessach und Ramadan sind
zusammengefallen und da hatte auch die
Hamas eigentlich sich das für sich
vorgenommen und gesagt wir werden jetzt
den Tempelberg für uns verteidigen
werden dadurch die Palästinenserbehörde
delikimitieren und haben dann aus dem
Gazastreifen eine Rakete in Richtung
Jerusalem abgefeuert als man also um das
unter dem Tempelberg als es da auch
ähnliches Szenarien gab das ist
natürlich auch durch die Verbreitung in
sozialen Medien von solchen Ereignissen
wirklich ein ein Brennpunkt den man dann
sehr schnell für sich vereinnahmen kann
und die Hamas seit zwei Monaten ist
eigentlich dabei sich also auf diesen
Moment vorzubereiten und zu sagen das
wird eine ein Zeitpunkt der
Konfrontation werden und da werden wir
uns ähm
wenn wir alles tun um da für die für die
Muslime einzutreten und da passiert auch
dass die Hamas hat eigentlich kein
Interesse dass man mit dem Gazastreifen
jetzt einen neuen Krieg beginnt sondern
möchte eigentlich Jerusalem West
jordanland da sich sich sich besser
festsetzen da ihre sich als die wahren
Vertreter der der muslimischen
Palästinenser im Westjordanland und
Jerusalem darzustellen
es heißt das Israel versucht haben soll
nachdem sich Palästinenser
verbarrikatiert hatten in der in der
Alexa Moschee mit Stöcken und
Feuerwerkskörpern dass man Jordanien
gebeten hat die Leute doch zu überzeugen
aus dieser Moschee wieder rauszugehen
aber das hat nicht funktioniert und dann
ist die Polizei da hineingegangen da
stellt sich halt natürlich schon die
Frage inwiefern da
diese Regierung jetzt noch mal anders
reagiert hat aber man hatte mehr oder
weniger eine ähnliche Situation schon
vor zwei Jahren nur jetzt ist man
tatsächlich durch die Proteste in Israel
durch mehrere Fronten diesmal man hat
jetzt auch noch die Front im Norden
zusätzlich in einer Lage der ja wo die
Dinge sehr schnell in einen mehrfronten
Krieg ausarten könnten was eigentlich
immer so einen Horror-Szenario war eben
gleichzeitig von mehreren Fronten mit
Raketen umgehen zu müssen die Hamas
hatte ja auch gestern Abend schon aus
dem Gazastreifen auch Raketen geschickt
und da muss man jetzt schauen ob in
dieser Lage wie sich da die Situation
wieder beruhigen lässt
auf jeden Fall wieder beruhigen lässt da
sagen sie natürlich das richtige wobei
es gibt auch Sorgen eben von unseren
Usern zum Beispiel die von Thore Wagner
der sich fragt könnte es
Vergeltungsschläge gegen den Libanon
geben auch um von innenpolitischen
Themen abzulenken fügt er noch hinzu
also das ist auch eine eine wichtige
Frage ich meine normalerweise kann man
davon ausgehen dass in so einem
Sicherheitskabinett ich habe die drei
Personen vorhin erwähnt die das
entscheiden haben da wird man sicherlich
nicht auf auf die Extremisten in der
Regierung wie Ben wir und und uns Modric
die beiden Minister hören die selber
nicht in der Armee gedient haben die
keinerlei Erfahrungen haben noch
irgendwelche Expertenwissen haben dazu
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass man
da dass die irgendeinen Einfluss darauf
haben werden aber allein dass man sich
diese Frage auch als israelischer Wähler
und und Bürger stellen muss nämlich wie
weit könnte es im Interesse liegen jetzt
von Benjamin netanjah wo die Leute
wieder zu vereinen wenn wenn es zu
solchen Gefahrensituationen kommt
verweist natürlich auf eine sehr heikle
Situation die mit der ihnen politischen
Lage zu tun hat
ich denke schon dass die Armee die nach
wie vor das größte Vertrauen der der
Bevölkerung genießt weit über allen ein
Institutionen da schon in der Lage ist
sich mit ihren eigenen Einschätzungen
durchzusetzen und dass der
Verteidigungsminister in jedem Fall da
auch Teil davon ist und man kann jetzt
da sagen man kann auch nur hoffen dass
netanjaho derjenige ist der früher in
dieser Hinsicht war nämlich in solchen
Situationen war ja jemand der als
riskerverse gilt also jemand der eher
Risiko scheu war und nicht jemand der
sagt jetzt erst recht es gibt es Leute
die sagen mir hat es heute nicht mehr
mit demselben netten ja auch zu tun wie
mit einem netten ja auch von vor zwei
Jahren das wird man sehen ich denke dass
die die Zahl der Raketen die heute aus
dem Libanon auf Israel kam
nicht unbeantwortet bleiben wird
allerdings muss es auch nicht heißen
dass man jetzt sofort reagiert deshalb
tritt auch dieses Kabinett zusammen um
gemeinsam zu beraten was sind eigentlich
die strategischen
Ziele wenn es die Hamas äh tatsächlich
so war die da dahinter stand dann muss
man da möglicherweise auch nicht sofort
reagieren man muss auch nicht unbedingt
gegen die Hamas dann im Libanon im
Südlibanon reagieren die haben was jetzt
auch noch an anderen Orten im
Gazastreifen in Katar oder in der Türkei
also da gäbe es noch andere
Möglichkeiten ich denke über genauso
eine solche Fragen wie man angemessen
strategisch reagiert darüber wird gerade
im Sicherheitskabinett beraten
Einschätzung von Professor Dr Gisela DAX
vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns heute Abend
zu Gast waren und auch Monika schwarz
übrigens für unsere erste Userin bedankt
sich für die ausführliche Antwort auf
ihre Frage ich hoffe das hat Frau Dachs
noch gehört sie schreibt die Userin wir
können nur das Beste hoffen und wir sind
natürlich für euch ihr seid jederzeit
bei uns informiert aktuell bei heute.de
im Netz bei ZDF heute könnt ihr euch
informieren denn da wird sich bestimmt
noch einiges tun wenn jetzt gerade das
sicherheitskabine zusammensetzt also
bleibt immer gerne bei uns informiert
und jetzt erstmal danke für eure
Aufmerksamkeit für den Moment schönen
Abend für euch und bis dahin tschüss